hi i'm max keiser this is the kaiser
report well what we've been reporting on
for a few years money printing
leads to inflation this is now becoming
a big problem for central banks around
the world
only one central bank in the world is
actually taking it on board and
proactively dealing with the issue we'll
get to that in a moment stacy
right well the money printing has been
going across of course the u.s across
europe
japan they've all been printing money
japan's the first to
go money printer gopro years and years
ago decades ago
but we're going to get to the central
bank of russia is
apparently going to be raising rates yet
again in a shock and awe moment
but first i want to lay out the
situation of what's going on and why we
have this wealth and income
gap and just the extraordinary moment in
which we are
we've covered the extraordinary nature
of negative interest rates we've covered
the extraordinary
nature of the money printing and
negative energy prices all the crazy
things that happen when price signals go
astray
well households corporate equities and
mutual fund shares
asset market value levels have expanded
by 8.8 trillion dollars
in asset value between q4 2019 and
q1 2021 the fastest and largest
valuation expansion in history
so you kind of see that in the data
where you see that the fed's
interventions get
sharper and faster and harder so that's
after the 2000 2001.com
crash it was a slow decline for a few
years like four or five years
and then it hit bottom and slowly came
back to life here's the 2008 crash
you see and what you see is that there's
a kind of like a u-shaped bottom
we had a v-shaped week
of declines back in march of 2020 and
now
the move the value asset valuations have
gone parabolic
right that's kind of the history of this
show kaiser report
we've been tracking that exact progress
from
the money printing and what it does and
we're at the inflection point now
where you can't mask it anymore like
they used to
because remember financial engineers on
wall street they were able to
figure out a way to print money but have
it go around the labor market
right so wages have been flat in the
before this recent derivatives
led financial engineering era that we
live in when
money supply increased wages would go up
you see and that was a price signal and
then you'd have
the business cycle but the the bankers
under starting with alan greenspan
figured out how to
just ignore labor completely and let
wages stagnate and just give the money
directly to their friends on wall street
and their benefactors and
okay so they said that there's no
inflation
but under covid they had to start
printing directly and shipping it right
from the treasury
as we've reported it's not like a
central bank operation anymore it's
direct money printing
and on top of the structural
collapse that's been occurring for a
while and this is now leading to
a hyperinflation the bankers themselves
now admit inflation they say it's
transitory
which is a lie of course it's structural
it's going to be a secular
inflationary move only one bank in the
world is taking this
taking this seriously that's the bank of
russia right but let's talk about this
moment of asset prices increasing
exponentially because
we've seen exponential growth everybody
now in the world understands us because
of covid right
you see how viruses spread exponentially
it looks slow at first and then it goes
parabolic
well that's kind of what has happened
with
debt in fiat so we're 50 years in august
it'll be 50 years that we have an all
fiat world
and we have interventionist increasingly
interventionist central banks especially
in the western world
and so what you've seen is a a
sort of doubling and quadrupling and
eight tupling octupling uh down doubling
down on all your bad bets and
and leverage so it makes sense because
you know the fed steps in
the greenspan put the yellow input the
bernanke put all that stuff they come in
a rescue
so it makes sense to that it
incentivizes this doubling down
and increasing of leverage so we're at
that parabolic move now
uh especially on if you put it on top of
a finite economy
we also have a similar thing with the
network effect the exponential growth of
networks we saw that with the internet
but i want to turn to this uh tweet from
willie wu
who's talking about bitcoin and what
you're seeing with bitcoin penetration
the human genome project
launched in 1990 by 1998 it was
at two percent progress so it took eight
years to get to two percent
the project reached completion by 2003.
this is the nature of exponential growth
bitcoin's adoption doubles
every year it is currently at two
percent global
penetration slowly slowly then all at
once
and here's that chart right there you
know think of a lily pads
right in a pond it takes them a while to
cover half the pond
and then the next move they double again
and they cover the entire pond
right that's exponential growth and
that's why it's shocking to people the
human mind can't really
take this on board so whether it's the
human genome project or the internet
or bitcoin or debt now what we're saying
about debt is that
the debt's been increased and been
doubling for years and years and years
and now we're at a point where the next
bail out of these banks and
they're going to get bailed out again
they have to double the money supply
again they have to double m1 again so it
means they have to go from
what is it now 10 trillion or so to 20
or 25 trillion in one
in one swoop right so then you that's
how you get your hyperinflationary
collapse and the dollar collapse and
that's what bitcoin's been telling us
all along
and you know it's amazing that these
phds from yale like ben bernanke
or nobel prize winning economist like
paul krugman at the new york times
don't understand exponential functions
you know it's incredible that they have
they they have gainful employment
writing about this stuff
and of course when it all happens
they'll say they never saw it coming
they'll blame it on something else paul
krugman will blame it on aliens they're
already seeding the alien argument by
claiming that there's a lot more ufos
out there
right of course but it's also about
incentive structures of course
so the exponential growth is i think
parabolic growth is happening
at the end of the life span of the
boomers
who started in 1971 they were
like 18 19 20 years old that was the
beginning of their working life
now we're at the very end of it you see
the parabolic move and now what do you
see the parabolic move into bitcoin
because
bitcoin is for millennial and generation
z they see the
numbers they see the mathematics there
that uh
the exponential debt is not something
they're way too late to the ponzi scheme
of fiat
the fiat grid to participate right so
they're just going to go to bitcoin
you see that in even places like india
this number as young indians are turning
to crypto instead of gold
a follow-up to that is indians invested
38.8 billion dollars in bitcoin and
crypto in the last 12 months
a huge 19 900 increase from 200 million
just one year ago you know obviously
gold is very ingrained in the population
as a
store of value now uh the younger people
there in india
are buying bitcoin and adopting bitcoin
yeah there has to be a word for
something that means deja vu but a
continuous deja vu
that is like annoyingly deja vu
because you know this indian story the
indian
population having 20 000 tons of gold is
totally
ingrained in their culture their
civilization for thousands of years that
gold
is the way to go and for five years now
since we first invested in unicoin five
years ago the first bitcoin exchange in
india
we've been saying that the indian
mindset's gonna shift to bitcoin
and every time we say that people have
said you're
absolutely insane that's never gonna
happen and now it's happening
so it's again like a bad version of deja
vu
where i've been we've been right 100 of
the time
almost without exception on
dozens and dozens of key points as it
relates to sovereignty remember we
predicted a sovereign would take on
bitcoin like
they have in el salvador we predicted
india would take on bitcoin
uh we predicted the hash wars we
predicted geothermal energy
and every step of the way people have
been viciously violently
you know trolling us that's wrong man
i'm just right every day i'm right i'm
right i'm right
i'm right i'm right again right in fact
there was a tweet stream uh
somebody just retweeted from 2013 where
you were
dean baker who's an economist was you
know you were
laughing at japan going down the road of
more print money printing
and you said hey i've got my bitcoin and
you know bitcoin was like five hundred
dollars and he's like yeah good luck
with that keep buying it buddy
and obviously that's uh many many times
over that
but again you mentioned mindset that
mindset set
just shifts suddenly and then you can't
ever go back
right so once these young people now
have
they're all in bitcoin they see bitcoin
as digital gold
and there's no going back they're not
going to adopt their mom and grandmom's
you know gold standard so the mindset
and we talk about this all the time
about the shifting mindset
of the younger generation and the split
that's happening and
you see that in the words of elvira
nabilena of the
central bank of russia what she's saying
about why their plan to basically shock
in all the markets with an interest rate
increase while fed is in denial hawkish
bank of
russia sees inflation as not transitory
warns of possible shock and awe rate
hike so consumer price inflation in
russia is red-hot having jumped six
percent in may compared to a year ago
two percentage points above the bank of
russia's target of four percent
polls in russia show that food inflation
is a top concern
currently running at 7.4 percent but he
points out that
you know they're increasing rates while
the fed is saying that
this bump in all the commodity prices
and food inflation and all that stuff
is just transitory so they keep on
surprising
to the upside they keep on surprising
economists in fact
wall street says russia has been on the
opposite trajectory of the u.s fed
surprising economists at every step
along the way
this trajectory started on march 19 with
a 25 basis point hike
to 4.5 percent against the expectations
of
27 of the 28 economists pulled by
reuters who didn't expect a rate hike
on april 23rd the bank of russia hiked
its policy rate by 50 basis points
to five percent on june 11 that height
did another 50 basis points to 5.5
percent
the next policy meeting is scheduled for
july 23rd
and the central bank of russia has
warned that it could it
will expect to increase rates between 25
basis points and 100 basis points
right well she's defending the currency
she's defending the ruble that's the job
of the central bank
to be you know to defend your
your national interest using interest
rates only in the united states
at the central bank abdicated their role
of
defending the rights of americans in
favor
of the kleptocratic privileges of the
oligarchs
oligarchs that run america oligarchs
that run america right so the the other
thing is that a lot of economies
russia being one of them but many
economies around the world don't like a
lot of debt so the u.s seems to think
that's a solution i think that
okay we'll just create another
quadrillion and bad debts
and that will cause inflation to mask
the
inflation they'll have deflation to mass
inflation
you know they seem to like try to
balance those out
rather than the price of money right so
deflation is
another more more accurately should be
referred to as a soft default
yes so the americans defaulting on their
debt again as they did in 1971 there's a
massive default on american debt they're
defaulting on their debt again and when
you default on your debt
and russia is already completely out of
the dollar
they're not they're like i'm not good
i'm not touching that
anyway we're going to take a break when
we come back much more coming here
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max kaiser time now to return to our
conversation with
mitch feierstein author of planet ponzi
mitch welcome back
great to be here okay greg foss a former
high yield bond trader turned bitcoiner
says that a negative yielding bond is
not investment
and yet there is about 19 trillion
dollars seemingly invested
in these bonds what do you make of this
well that's craziness because you know a
lot of these funds have it in their
you know prospectus it's part of the
mandate that they have to buy x amount
of these bonds no matter what it doesn't
talk about negative yield
because when the you know when the
prospectuses were set up for a lot of
these
pension funds um they they mandated
because they thought it was one of the
safest investments that you could be in
to be in certain types of bonds and
fixed income products and
a lot of the fixed income products
you're talking about now are negative
yielding but you know real
interest rates are negative yielding
when you look at it you know
i said this to you years ago i said look
if i had anybody that worked for me
that bought a negative yielding bond i
would fire them quite frankly
i mean there's no reason why anybody
should buy a negative yielding bond
i mean you should if you're if you're
that if you have that sort of issue
you better find a better way to put your
money to work than putting it into
negative yielding bonds because that
implies
what that implies is there's zero credit
risk
and a lot of these bonds that are
trading at negative rates there's more
than zero credit risk i can tell you so
what's happened is with the distortions
by the central banks
printing hundreds of trillions in in
cash and guarantees equivalence what
they've done is distorted the market to
such a point that people no longer know
how to price risk how to identify risk
and how to quantify risk
so the market pricing mechanism has been
broken
and nobody there are no adults in the
room to come out and say
look this is not the way that we should
move forward if we want a booming
economy
right now we're seeing we're seeing
we're in the bottom of the ninth inning
and there's probably two outs so i i
don't think that we have room to run
here
i think that we're about to hit a brick
wall and it's not going to be very
pretty so trust
has been eroded across the spectrum i
mean you know we had this infrastructure
bill that was
said that they're going to pass in the
senate with another trillion or so
dollars
you had the president come out 10
minutes later and change
change the game plan so does that
increase trust you know he
he denied what he said and said oh only
if you give it five billion more for
something else
so that doesn't help with the trust of
government which is at an all-time
historic low in america
but equities prices are an all-time high
real estate valuations including
commercial real estate and residential
real estate are
skyrocketing you know it makes houses
unaffordable and
you know you've got the rentier class
coming in now to buy up all the real
estate with the cheap money from the
federal reserve
so that they can keep people as debt
surfs so
you know you've got a very very negative
feedback loop going on here
with these fake interest rates created
by money printing so you've got a lot of
fake things going on that need to be
resolved in the markets before we can
really
move forward right well what you're
describing there with these pension
funds right they've got
fiduciary responsibility they've got
prospectus says they're obligated to buy
treasuries it's on the books it's a rule
they're not
changing the laws purposefully
because people in congress are working
with the bankers to commit a massive
fraud
a loophole to bail out bankers bankers
are able to sell
essentially tainted meat right they're
selling something they know is
is uh is garbage that that can't
possibly
uh make any money you're selling an
original issue loss
and uh it's a bailout it's a rolling
bailout
and um it's um it's extortion it's
extortion so you've got banks
essentially going to pension funds these
are people savings
putting the gun to their head saying
we've got you by
you know we've got you buy
this junk that's guaranteed to lose
money and it's guaranteed to lose money
or will blow your brains out so
washington and washington collude
to perpetrate a massive fraud on
people's savings accounts
the most egregious example of what
you're talking about max is where
italian bonds are trading but you know
you have
mario draghi and this character was at
goldman sachs
he was at the bank of italy and he
convinced
uh the bank to to issue all these bonds
so they did through goldman
um then he went from from goldman to
bank of italy to the ecb and now he's
the prime minister of italy so they keep
getting the same people they're like bad
pennies that keep appearing so
until they can get fresh ideas and and
end this corruption cycle we're not
going to get out of this loop until it
explodes
and then i hope they don't bring larry
summers back to to bail us out of this
you know this is what happens you just
get you you
it's the definition of insanity when you
keep doing the same thing over and over
and expect to achieve a different result
we're just getting deeper and deeper in
because the debts just keep getting
bigger and we're not creating
manufacturing we're not creating organic
growth which is what drives an economy
not financialization
so we've been on the wrong track for at
least 30 years here and to turn the
train around
the titanic around on a dime is not
going to happen
but it's going to happen with the next
crisis that we're going to see
substantial change the banks will
probably get blamed
and what they'll probably do is try to
have some sort of global entity take
over
everything to really insert globalism
in as the global rulers will now take
care of
everything to solve the problems because
we can't allow those bankers and we
can't allow the central banks who
created this mess to do it again
and then you'll have a bunch of um
oligarchs running everything which is
close to what we're doing and you're
seeing that now that radical ideologies
that are being broadcast fun
you know broadcast by a lot of the
politicians out there and you can never
argue just like you can't ever tape for
a ponzi scheme
you can never have an argument with an
ideologue
because you'll never win because even if
you show them
a video of something happening they're
gonna say it's fake or you show them
that two and two equals four they're
gonna say no it equals six
because that's the way ideologues are so
this is the problem that you have and i
think they're trying to create
extreme polarization which is what
they've done so you've got like a a
bolshevik
woke wash revolution going on designed
to divert attention from 30 years of the
failed policies
that enables the biggest wealth
inequality
that gap that we've ever seen in history
the great
and while in the background the greatest
economic plunder is going on
and the bailouts for billionaires
continue and they take all that they can
out now
and then when it hits the fan then then
the chips are going to get you know it's
anybody's bet what happens but it'll
probably end up in civil war or
or even worse maybe a world war the
bankers that are doing all this printing
and
stealing all this money it's not like
they're immune from the
the impact of it i mean a lot of them
live out there in the hamptons
and as a corollary to all their money
printing and
thievery you've got a septic problem
they're literally drowning in their own
feces out there in east hampton
and and the rest of the hamptons in new
york because of their own policies but
i guess what they've decided to do is
try to market that right they'll get
calvin klein to market feces as
some great sen smelling scent and
cologne
that they'll just get and that'll fail
and they'll get another bailout
right so it's they're they've monetized
financial terrorism that's the bottom
line and and you when once you go
to that place then you never lose
and the guarantee of an uprising is 100
percent mentioned
look at what happened with the airlines
i mean there's one airline in particular
i won't mention the name but i wrote an
article about them the ceo paid himself
150 million dollars he was paid 100
in equity which is unheard of right
so all he did was buy the company's
shares so he took 13 billion dollars
and plunked it down to bump up the share
price instead of building the balance
sheet and strengthening the balance
sheet for a rainy day
so what happened when we had the covid
crisis was
oh that's it we need to get a bailout
this guy is still there so they got
20 billion in bailouts if he hadn't been
a profligate spender with
a share buybacks um they would have had
money and they wouldn't have needed so
much of a taxpayer bailout which the
government said they were never
going to do again and they did but that
guy is still the ceo of that airline
and he's now got he's using he's using
wokewash
to say oh now we're diverse we're going
to do this as a sideshow
which is this is what people should
realize this identity politics
and this woke movement is all a sideshow
to
divert attention away from the economic
plunder that's going
on and that's the deeper part of this
and the component that people need to
realize and say wait a second
we've got to connect the dots here and
look at what's really going on behind
the scenes it's just an
oligarchy that's looking to rule us and
insert globalism
i like this phrase woke wash so that's
my answer to my question i've been
asking now
how do they get away with it because
nobody in washington
in the banking industry or the media
wants to call them out
on this obvious fraud and i guess the
answer is
walk wash say they've concatenated a
narrative
about even though they're stealing
everything
and causing the rest of the world to
flush america down the toilet
um everyone's gonna be woke while it
happens
so that's okay is that what i'm hearing
mitch right when you circle
the ball you're gonna be woke when you
go down but it's gonna be diverse you're
gonna
be flushed in a diverse way right so
that's pretty much
what's going on in my view so i i think
that what we need now
is we need to have real enforcement of
the existing regulations that we have on
the books
and we need not one rule for one party
one rule for another party
we need equal justice and equal
application of justice to everybody we
can't have this partisan bickering
and we can't have judges ruling from the
bench
there are existing laws and statutes
that exist we have a u.s constitution
and contrary to it people say the
constitution is fixed in america
and those laws are what they are there's
no
way to change them from the bench this
must be legislated
there are ways to do it and the way that
there's an
end around now for everything is just
crazy and
it's alienating people as part of this
wash diversion
let's talk about some of the specifics
here you know you do have a lot of
supply shortages developing
and this is uh they can't hide this you
know they can't hide the fact that
semiconductors and other key components
in the supply chains are breaking down
and walk washing i don't think that's
gonna work if somebody
um suddenly can't get a part to fix
their car
or to fix their air conditioning the
parts are unavailable and they're
freezing or overheating there's a huge
heat wave down the
in the northwest and the northeast is
walk wash gonna convince these people
that
it's okay if they freeze to death or
burn alive
no it's not absolutely not but look what
they're doing is
the the supply chain has has been um
has been irreparably damaged by kovid
in certain aspects but this was
happening before kovit
we've had a supply chain issue when
everything was outsourced for cheaper
labor in other countries and we're being
held hostage
look there are certain industries that
are a matter of national security where
the product should be produced
in the united states or in the sovereign
country like britain
where wherever the country needs things
that are
that are critical to the security of
that nation like all the
integral chemicals that go into
antibiotics are produced in china
you know and china during the peak of
the covet crisis
threaten to withhold certain chemicals
that go into antibiotics that are really
necessary
now that nobody in the world or no
country should be able to be held
hostage like that with the supply chain
and the supply chains broke down during
the covid crisis so
you know even if all the truck drivers
one day said we're not going to deliver
any more think about the damage that
that does to the supply chains
the cost of delivering things when oil
goes up 75 percent
as it has in the past seven or eight
months
triples yeah remember you're scaring me
now i i i i'm um i can't take it
we got to cut it off there mitch
firestein thanks for being on kaiser
report
thanks for having me back all right
that's going to do it for this edition
of kaiser report with me max keiser and
stacey herbert want to thank our guest
mitch feierstein author of planet ponzi
until next time bye y'all
[Music]